God of War Ragnarok will soon give us
the epic showdown to end all showdowns
as the gods of Norse myth finally faced
their final battle while Kratos at the
same time navigates his way through the
action and one of the major players in
Norse mythology and Ragnarok itself will
also end up as kratos's main antagonist
the God of Thunder himself Thor
so let's become the gods of lore as we
take a look at how Thor initially
appeared in Norse mythology discuss how
that compares to what we already know
about the Thunder God in the game and
what that might mean for his ultimate
fate as the end times Ragnarok itself
Thunders closer when we think of Thor
today we tend to Envision the Marvel
version of the character young
incredibly charismatic honorable Noble
chiseled abs and bearing the face of
arguably the best of all the Hollywood
Chris's the brain is a muscle and that's
a muscle and that's a muscle and they
are all muscles this is all muscle so I
am covered in brains and I'm more brains
than you this
why many people seem
Thor showed up in the God of War
Ragnarok promotional material looking
like this
a vastly different depiction than what
we're used to but actually this
appearance and demeanor are much more in
line with Norse myth than the Marvel
version of the character is in Legend
Thor is known as the strongest Warrior
of the Acer the Norse gods and he's
unrivaled in strength and power today
though we equate strength and power
especially for men with zero body fat
and a toned body but this isn't the only
way to be fit nor was that body type the
expectation of a fit person when
Scandinavians worshiped Thor instead
having a stout body was actually
considered a way to Showcase that you
had won many battles and were thus able
to feed Yourself by celebrating your
victories with food drink and song
incredibly liberally and indeed this is
something mythological Thor did a ton of
with endless stories of him loving to
celebrate even having been described as
eating a whole Ox ate salmon and three
whole gallons of mead in a single
sitting many stories in Norse myth
revolve around on Thor just wanting to
go out and get drunk one story even
involves Thor going all the way out of
his way to find an excellent cauldron to
brew Alin For A Feast of the Gods
traveling all the way Far East and
causing trouble with other gods along
the way to secure the kettle so right
away God of War Ragnarok accurately
depicts Thor as it aligns with Norse
mythology yet here is where God of War's
depiction of the Thunder God begins to
differ from Norse myth while in Norse
mythology Thor is undoubtedly an
imperfect hero often being
short-tempered easily enraged and even
somewhat racist towards Giants and
dwarves he's generally an honorable
Warrior and ideal to be aspired to often
defending the honor of those around him
in one tale Thor arrived at a feast to
find the visiting giant herognir drunk
and boasting about how he could kill all
the other gods including Freya and Sif
Thor's wife Thor angry at hierognir for
dishonoring his family lifted his hammer
mjolnir in order to kill hiragi here
right there but the giant stopped him by
accusing Thor of cowardice for
attempting to murder an unarmed man and
challenged him instead to a duel Thor
accepted the challenge and the next day
eventually killed ragnir in the duel by
hitting his head with his hammer so hard
that his head split open but at the same
time the giant managed to permanently
launch a piece of his Whetstone in
Thor's head for his troubles so all in
all an honorable Duel at least by a Seer
standards yet in God of War 2018 this
story is revealed to have been a
fabrication a story told to make Thor
seem better than he actually was I saw
the AC Allah leapt upon his shield and
swore he'd kill us all and take out
women fought back to jotenheim
Dan Thor shows up and just heal off oh
no
Thor takes one look at the drunken Stone
buffoon and brings down mjolnir on his
head so hard that he's got chunks of
lunia in his own skull to this day
I thought it's so startled by the face
full of rock he doesn't notice sunnier's
body topple right onto him with a
sickening crunch
and again
the Roars of laughter echoed through the
palace Halls
that's an awful story my mirror nothing
like the one's mother told me
might that be a lesson my son
truth is seldom so pretty as myth
enlightened this version of the tale
told by mimir in the game reveals that
Thor just showed up and felt slighted by
hirogne or jokingly telling stories
about him and killed him out of his
disgraced honor all while the gods
laughed as they watched on as a man died
uncaring either way this less honorable
version of Thor stands in sharp contrast
to the Thor of myth to the Scandinavian
Vikings Thor was the god of the people
Gods like Odin were the elites worthy of
worship but consistently above others
wielding magic and other powers that an
average person could never touch in
comparison while certainly stronger than
an average human Thor's power came
simply from his strength something that
any human could have and was an
attribute that many in Viking Society
valued Thor was relatable a hero who you
could quite literally have a beer with
this is not so much true for the Thor in
God of War while we never actually meet
Thor in God of War 2018 we do see his
effects on the lives of people that he's
encountered in one side quest you
encounter the spirit of a man whose
family worshiped Thor
my father passed my mother built the
statute
of grave imagine our surprise when the
God of Thunder himself came to offer
condolences
at first we were thrilled that he
quickly took advantage of our
hospitality
my mother begged him to leave and Thor
in his drunken rage killed her
I was left with nothing but grief
eventually I lost that as well
found only rage in its place
here we can see that the Thor of God of
War takes what he wants when he wants it
regardless of the consequences to
anybody else even to those who worship
him as Kratos himself says of this story
why did the gods cause so much trouble
for us because that is their
name this is perhaps the most
significant departure between Norse myth
and God of War's depiction of Thor where
Thor in mythology was relatable compared
to Odin for example both Thor and Odin
in the game are the elites who care
nothing for the Mortal Lies Beneath them
yet this depiction actually fits in with
the repeated theme of the entire God of
War franchise from the first game in the
series it has repeatedly been shown that
the gods whether they be Norse or Greek
care not for the lives of mortal men
the gods of Olympus have abandoned me in
the original trilogy on the PlayStation
2 and Playstation 3 Kratos is used as a
pawn in the Greek gods machinations who
don't really care for him as a person
even going so far as to bind him to
their service by tricking him into
killing his family after learning of
this Kratos became fueled and blinded by
rage and Kratos eventually murders the
entire Greek pantheon in his quest for
vengeance by the time of God of War 2018
though Kratos has managed to temper this
rage through his family but he
recognizes the same uncaring attitude in
the Norse gods that he saw in the Greek
ones as well as the lies that these Gods
tell Mortals to uphold the Mythos around
them a lesson he tries to pass on to his
son atreus with all that power you would
think at least some of them would try to
make life better for people and yet the
gods continue to spread misery Mrs life
boy so this depiction of Thor in God of
War despite not being completely aligned
with how Scandinavians viewed Thor in
myth fits perfectly within God of War's
themes and uses Norse mythology as
evidence within the story to affirm this
depiction of the Gods lies
I always knew Odie was bad
that's just useless automatic heartless
that's Odin in fact we would do well to
sit here in silence for the next few
moments and reflect on Odin's capacity
for cruelty yet Thor in the games also
reflects another theme how those in
power like the gods will do anything to
hold on to that power and the backstory
to God of War 2018 Thor learns of the
upcoming events of the World's End
Ragnarok where he is fated to die in a
battle with the world serpent
jormungound paranoid Thor has the
dwarves Brock and syndry make his hammer
mjolnir so that he might use it in order
to stop the events from coming to pass
he also makes his children soldiers
focused only on preventing Ragnarok and
even attempts to steal the Giant's
ability to see the future from the yotin
the Giants who managed to stop his
attempts upset by this failure Thor
turns his anger towards the yotin
killing many in his path however this
bloodlust eventually leads to Thor's
downfall as he is eventually stopped by
jormungound itself causing the very
rivalry that would eventually lead to
their final fight at the end of the
world in Ragnarok by attempting to stop
Ragnarok Thor slowly began to cause it
much of this story rhymes with Norse
Legend but it is distinctly different
from it for one Thor's hammer mjolnir is
made by Brock and syndrian myth but more
due to a playful bet by Loki a story I
discussed in a separate video on the
mythology behind Loki in the series but
moving on the Thor of Legend also had a
similar rivalry with yormign gown who in
this version is Loki's child but it's
more a battle of equals not one of
grudging hate many gods even attempt to
stop Thor and Norman gown from facing
each other in order to avoid Ragnarok
such as when the god himir cuts a
fishing line in order to prevent Thor
from Catching the serpent however while
the gods indeed fear and wish to prevent
Ragnarok and myth it is something that
is often avoided rather than something
actively attempted to be stopped as we
see in God of War yet this is ultimately
the story that God of War as a Series
has always been about the uncaring drive
of those in power towards those they
control and their unending willingness
to hold on to that power at the expense
of all others even themselves it speaks
perhaps to the two distinct eras in
which these stories are told Vikings of
old prided individual achievement with
Fame and honor being considered the only
things that carried on after you died
earning yourself a place in the annals
of History by your glorious deeds and
heroism ideals that the Thor of myth
reflected today however much of our
cultural conversation centers upon
issues of power who deserves it and
should anyone even have it in the first
place we today are much more likely to
distrust someone who seeks power for its
own sake and seems uncaring for the
collective good so using Thor as a
critique as a symbol of this class
discussion modernizes the context of
this character and also makes him fit
within the ideas that God of War
Ragnarok and the franchise as a whole
has always attempted to tackle head-on
or heads off depending on what Kratos
does to you but with all that said this
is where we leave Thor for now but if
you want to learn more about Norse
mythology and how it may tie into God of
War Ragnarok don't forget to subscribe
to this channel as we'll have another
God of lore video next week and in the
meantime check out all of our coverage
on God of War Ragnarok right here on
Gamespot